Let's see, um.
I guess there might be a trumpet from the
Bronx holding, is it my understanding that
correctly, are you a pro Trump person from
the Bronx?
Oh, opto, I was just just the name which goes.
You're not a Trump supporter.
Oh, not at all.
OK, what's going on?
Well, I just I'm you know, being a Democrat,
it's kind of hard to date somebody who's that
is, you know, a racist and a whore.
All right.
Republican.
So I was wondering, how do you recommend we
do we deal with that situation when your your
partner's family or Trump person are so far
right?
Well, let me ask you your partner's family
or your partner as well.
So, no, my my girlfriend is completely Democrat.
She's OK.
Hundred percent of her dad used to be a cop.
He actually got fired for, you know, using
racist tactics.
And I am.
And so it's kind of difficult for me to interact
with him.
So I'm wondering, what's it going to take?
So I'm understanding your girlfriend is not
Latino.
No, she is.
She's 100 percent white.
Yeah, that's tough.
I mean, listen, if if it were the actual partner,
I don't think I could do it.
You know, it's like if there's a difference
over the degree to which the gender pay gap
exists, it's like, listen, we can bridge that
gap.
That's no problem.
If there is a difference over, you know, some
nominal religious belief, I think that's fine.
I think it would be very difficult to actually
date a full on.
Trump is now the family.
The family, I think, is manageable.
If you think if you're careful and it's really
about how important it is for you to maintain
a relationship with her family.
I mean, there's people in my girlfriend's
family who are very conservative evangelical.
You know, we don't really see them just because
of distance.
But it's just, you know, you basically are
just agreeing not to talk about politics.
Is it?
Now, where it becomes difficult is sometimes
there will be people, Trump, who, even though
everybody knows it would be better not to
talk about politics, they because it pervades
their worldview, they can't help saying something
racist or whatever.
And you feel like I can't say nothing.
But at the same time, if I respond, I'm starting
a fight.
Those situations are really difficult.
I don't know how to manage them.
Right.
Don't I agree with you.
You know, Thanksgiving coming up.
Yeah.
Going to be difficult to be sure.
It's going to be a mess.
Now, I wonder it at multi at families that
are split politically by Thanksgiving, are
you going to have the Trump people insisting
that Joe Biden is an illegitimate president?
Because that's going to make for some awkward
pass the sweet potatoes moments?
You know, Bill, you're right.
Well, thank you so much for your advice.
Dude, I really appreciate your show.
I'm enjoying it more than ever now.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate you calling in.
Great.
To a great fun.
Wow.
What what phone calls today.
Let's go next to Tolia from is it Raleigh
or Raleigh, North Carolina.
I always forget how it's pronounced.
Yes, hi.
Hi, how are you?
Great.
It's so great to be talking to you, David.
Likewise.
So I have an interesting idea that I'd like
to run past you and see what you think.
Sure.
So recently you've seen like Democrats like
Joe Manchin, who basically I think Republicans
and get in the way of whenever Democrats and
maybe do something.
So I'm thinking we should run progressives
in the Republican Party.
I think our ideas would be great and they
would cancel out people like Joe Manchin.
And also, I think that it's important to not
just play offense, but also play defense.
And I mean, the Republicans do.
They definitely have Republican and Democratic
Party Joe Manchin.
And yeah, I was wondering if you think of
that, I'd have to think about that.
So the idea is instead of primary thing, Joe
Manchin with a progressive in the Democratic
primary, you run progressives in the Republican
primaries.
Everywhere.
I don't think we should just take over the
Democratic Party, probably take over the entire
government because.
Yeah, but I just don't see Republican primaries
going to progressives.
I think I think it could I think Republicans
would take too many progressive ideas like
we see in like Florida, where they're voting
for minimum wage and on these drug drugs,
winning the war on drugs.
If you run on issues like that, I think we
would get a lot of crossover.
Interesting.
I just I just don't I can't think of any place
where a progressive would win a Republican
primary.
But let me think about it a little more.
OK, Tolia.
Yeah.
All right.
Tolia from North Carolina, very much appreciate
the call that will do it recalls today, but
you're not.
We will take calls again in the future.